what's the perfect day in the life of
magnus carlson on a day of a big chess
match
it doesn't have to be world championship
but if if if it's a chess match you care
about what uh what time do you wake up
what do you eat
well it depends on when the game is but
let's say the game is at three um i'll
probably
wake up uh pretty
late at about
11
then i'll
go for go for a walk uh might listen to
some podcasts
maybe i'll spend a little bit of time
looking at some you know some nba game
from last night or whatever to not chess
related stuff no no no uh then i'll
i'll get back i'll have
big lunch like usually like a big omelet
with a bunch of salad and stuff
then go to the game
win like a very nice clean game
this is a perfect day just go back after
relax
like the the things that make me the
happiest at tournaments is just having a
good routine and feeling feeling well
i don't like it when
too much is happening around me so the
tournament that i came from now
was
the chess olympiad which is the team
event
so we were team norway
we did horribly
yeah uh i like i did okay but the team
in general did did horribly uh
italy
uh no no italy beat us but uzbekistan
won in the end they were this amazing
team of young players it was really it
was really impressive but the thing is
like we had a good camaraderie in the
team we had our meals together we played
a bit of football went swimming
and
i couldn't understand why things went
wrong and i still don't understand but
the thing is for me it was all very nice
but now i'm so happy to be on my own at
a tournament just to have my own
routines not see too many people yeah
otherwise just have like a very small
team of people that i see
you are a kind of celebrity now so
you know people within
the chess tournament and outside
recognize you want to socialize want to
tell you about how much you mean to them
how much you inspire them all that kind
of stuff does that get in the way for
you when you're like trying to really
focus on on the match are you able to
uh block that like are you able to enjoy
that those little interactions and still
keep your focus yeah most of the time
that's uh that's fine as long as it's
not too much but i have to admit
when i'm at home in norway
like i rarely
go out with like
without um big headphones and something
uh oh look at this guy on my no not just
black guys just to block out the world
yeah otherwise
um don't make eye contact yeah
so the thing is
people in general are nice i mean people
they wish me well
and
they don't like bother me also when i
have the headphones on i don't notice as
much people like turning around and yeah
and all of that so i can be more of in
my own world
so i like that yeah uh what about after
the the in this perfect day after the
game
do you try to analyze what happened do
you try to think through systematically
or do you just kind of loosely think
about like no i just loosely think about
it i i've never been very structured in
in that sense um
i know that
it was always recommended that you
analyze your your own games but i i
generally felt
that i mostly had a good idea about that
like nowadays i will like loosely
see what the engine says at a certain
point if i'm curious about that
otherwise i
usually move on to the next
what about diet you said almond and
salad and so on i heard uh in your
conversation with the uh with the other
magnus magnus number two about your you
had like this bet about meat
when are you gonna go vegan if you lose
i forget which vegetarian though uh
vegetarians
and uh you both have an admiration for
me is there um
is there some aspect about optimal
performance that you look for in food
like
maybe eating only like once or twice a
day or a particular kind of food like
meat heavy diet is there anything like
that or you just try to have fun with
the food yeah i think
um
whenever i'm at tournaments like it's
very natural to eat at least for me to
eat only twice a day so usually i do
that when i'm at home as well before so
you you do eat before the tournament
though you don't you don't play fasted
no no no um
but i try not to eat too heavy before
the game or
in general to avoid
sugary stuff to have
a pretty stable uh blood sugar level
because that's the easiest way to make
mistake that your your energy levels
just suddenly suddenly drop and they
don't necessarily mean need to be too
high as long as they're pretty stable
yeah have you ever tried playing fasted
like you know like
uh intermittent fasting so oh playing
without having eaten i mean the reason i
asked you know uh
i've especially when you do a low carb
diet when i have done a personal low
carb diet i'm able to fast for a long
time like eat once a day maybe uh twice
a day but i just the mind is most
focused on like really difficult
thinking tasks when it's fasted it's an
interesting a lot of people kind of talk
about that
yeah you're able to kind of like zoom in
and if you're doing a low carb diet you
don't have this energy the energy stable
no
that is true maybe that would be
interesting to try so what's happened
for me if i played a few tournaments
where i've had food poisoning
and then that generally means that
you're both sleep deprived and you have
no energy yeah and what i've found is
that
it makes me to some it makes me very
calm of course because i don't have
the energy and it makes me super
creative
like interesting being slipped if
probably i think in general makes you
creative
just the first thing that goes away is
the ability to do the simple things
that that's that's what if it affects
you the most like you cannot be precise
so i'm that's the only thing i'm worried
about like if if i'm faster that i won't
be
i won't be
[Music]
precise when i play
but you might be more creative
it's an interesting trusted yeah
potentially
you